And well, we already know each other, but well, one
question is if you could decipher
how exactly how many ballots
remain to be counted, if you
cannot decipher them, the provisional ones, the
ones that have been counted by mail,
and what
could we expect?  From that moment
on, of course, if we have 63,000 still
to count, we have 60,000 to count,
which are provisional, we are going to start
reviewing those votes today, starting
today, and we hope that by Sunday
we will have almost final figures, but of course,
the law allows us to  Let's count
until November 12,
only the breakdown is 60,000
provisionals that I am pending
plus 63 thousand 44 thousand plus 2100 we only have
63 thousand pending today we received by
mail 241 in total this morning that
we can still receive by law we can
receive the  that have the postmark
with the date of November 3,
we can also receive until today
ballots by mail that do not have  On the postal date,
Lorena, I will explain it a bit, but
we would like you to explain to us in
Spanish what has happened with this number
that initially they had given as what
50,000 are going to count, now there are thirty-
something thousand or two pages, which was
a mistake  If you could clarify, please, of
course, this time this year the
ballot in the general election has two
cards, so that was the mistake that
the cards were counted instead of the
electoral districts, so that's why
there are 30,000, that's it.  the correct figure
when they talk about this error on the
pages you are talking about an error in what
they indicated to the press, it is not an
error that obviously affects the votes,
can you clarify a bit because when you
say that there was an error, it may be
misinterpreted  of course, of course,
thanks for that, we want to clarify that
the same tickets are actually
being counted, right, but it was the
pages that were counting instead of
the tickets, the tickets continue  n being
the same figures
I know that the numbers the question has
been repeated many times but
frankly it does not end up being
completely clear you mentioned that
there were 60,000 that are counting
additional provisional in addition to
also additionally they have those that
have to be verified that you mentioned
provisional problems sorry 60,000
provisional 63 although we have
pending to count right now we are already
beginning to count those ballots we have
received by post
the ones that arrived this morning 241
so to clarify why it is what
we have left very confusing there are
three categories one the  that they are
counting 60 thousand second category there are
3 thousand 63 thousand second category the
provisional ones you call them 60 thousand 60 thousand and
third category those that arrive by
mail 241 yesterday if we wanted to separate that
figure so that they understand that right now
they are counting the 63 thousand that  we have
pending but we also receive 241
so that  Please understand that by law
we have until November
6 today to receive mail-in ballots that
do not have a postal date and we also have
until November 10 to receive
mail-in ballots that have a
November 3 postal date
apart from these three categories  that
we have just mentioned, including the one from
the post office, are there any other types of
ballots that have to be counted or that
would be all if Mr. Gloria also
mentioned that there are 44
in this figure, that is why there may be
confusion, so we need the
identification,
that is why we wanted  separate it so that they would
understand what the sand is
clear about the 63,000 that of the 60,000 and
I only have one doubt left with that number of the
33 thousand that tells me the thirty-odd
thousand that are at the beginning that I already know with
everything and that  It is what is going to be reformed
well in the afternoon if it is going to be reported
before four in the afternoon but that
is already within the process the count is already
perfect the matter of verification of the
ident  Until when do
people have time to do that
today until 5 pm the people
who still owe us the
Nevada ID can come to our offices
at our office and we are at 965
trade drive not las vegas' 890 30  and
we also have our line in Spanish
available if you have any questions
at 70 24 55 300 66 it
is time for the question of the
global global figure sorry or universal that there is
Mr. Glory spoke of 20,500 what does he mean
with that figure 20 thousand 500
no  I know which figure is scary,
but I will have to speak later to be
able to give you that proper answer.
So,
nice to Univision. Let me
ask you, please,
the work calendar that you are going
to have, for how long will you still
be counting tickets, when is the
date you have  to render their
last preparation to send carson
been on november 12 is the last time
we are going to finish the count we have until
that date to receive all the  ballots and
also the voter has until
November 12 to cure his signature if his
signature was not properly identified verified
if he did not include it in his
return envelope he has until November 12
to come verify that
signature with us on the 16th  We
will have the final results in November
and we are going to present it to the
commissioners.
Can you also tell us a little bit
about the healing process because
people have questions
about the signing of the ballot, there are people
who
may be that the person did not include  your
signature on the return envelope or it did not
pass the verification that we have which is
very meticulous from the signature to is a
part that by law we have to do the
same as we do in person we also
verify the signature of each voter and
the voter if it does not pass  That verification
of the signature we communicate by
email by phone
and also by mail so that they can
do it in person by an application the
secretary of  he state has told us that
many people have participated in this
for reasons of the pandemic and of course
convenience and we can also do it
by phone. We have a center where
we are receiving calls at 4 5 5 6
552 where if the person has any
questions about it we will  You can call the
last question I have,
there was a lot of talk about the patience
people have to have to get a
result. We know how many people are
working in this process, counting the
tickets, they
have hired extra staff and what
time they are working now
because  Well, think that they are
taking a bit of time, of course, we do have
several shifts, I would have to give you all
the schedules, but we can be here
from five in the morning to eleven
at night and several teams that are
working very hard and are very
dedicated to their work.
and let's hope that by Sunday they have
the most current and final figures
that we can give them
more or less 200 a cue  stion
then if you can make your comments
on this but Mr. Blair was
also talking about the security that they
are observing here in the department
as they are monitoring social networks
can you tell us about that please
we feel very safe but
he would have to comment on  that
thanks of
course I am an assistant
voter registrar petition march thanks good
day